Learner A4: السلام عليكم.
Learner A1: السلام عليكم.
Learner A4: وعليكم السلام.
Learner A7: وعليكم.
Learner A1: الدنيا ونعمة للوقت.
Learner A4: تقريبا مش مش سامية كل.
Mentor A: صباح الخير.
Learner A7: صباح النور.
Learner A4: النور.
Learner A1: صباح النور.
Mentor A: سامعيني كده طيب.
Learner A7: ، اوكي تمام.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي عملتوا
Learner A4: أم هو أسامة عمل حاجة هو طريقه مش عارف يتكلم دلوقتي بس هو
Learner A4: حاجة زي اللي انت كنت بعتها بالظبط ولي العون حضرتك.
Mentor A: أوكي طلع من صح طلع من.
Learner A4: لأن الباي بلان برضه مع كل ما كانوش
Learner A4: ما كناش خالص يعني مثلا مصطفى لسا اعملوا مبارح.
Mentor A: إيه طب ثانية واحدة الضمير ده اللي هو دخلها بي
Mentor A: يعني جايبها عادي من بس حطيتها في نفس الستروكتور اللي بيطلع من.
Learner A4: ، مظبوط.
Mentor A: طيب وريني كدا.
Learner A4: وأنا هو برضه على.
Mentor A: إمم توت.
Learner A4: هو اشتغل اللي كنت ماشي عليه، وأنا كنت قلتلو على ودي، فهو دخل ودي قال مع اللي انت كنت شغالة بيه هو تقريبا كان اسمه دوم حاجة
Learner A4: و أنا خدت الستروكتور دا وبدأت برضو اللي انا ادور وكدا أحسن ممكن نطلعه منه
Learner A4: فالمفروض ان تجريت برضه على النهارده بحاجة تانية اسمها ريموشن
Learner A4: دي حاجه بتبقى بتخلي يعني الفيديو انتيراكتيون
Learner A4: في نفس الوقت بتخليه داون لود.
Mentor A: دي بتعمل إيه يعني بس إنت عندك هي دي اللي بتحول من اتش تي ام ال امري فور ولا دي بتعمل بالزبط.
Learner A4: دي كدا كدا بتحول ام تي فور وبنفس الوقت يعني اللي حضرتك تبعته واللي سمع عمله وانت اللي احنا بدأنا بالفيديو حضرتك ما تقدريش توقف.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: لا تقدري توقفي ولا تقدري تعملي أي حاجة ولا ترجعي لورا ولا أي حاجة من الكلام ده.
Mentor A: بس عيد.
Learner A4: الباب.
Mentor A: ده لما يتحول ام بي فور عادي تقدر توقفه هو الام بي فور بيبقى.
Learner A4: هو ده.
Mentor A: عربات.
Learner A4: هو ده أكيد بس هو يبتدي مثلا اللي بيتفرج على
Learner A4: اللي بيتفرج على الفيديو هو مش عايز ينزله دلوقتي او هو بس حابب ان هو يشوف على الويب سايت او في معلومة سقطت منه
Learner A4: ده بيخلي السكوب اوسع شوية اللي هو بس على حتة اللي هو فيديو كريديشن هو ممكن كمان يبقى كورس فاهمة قصدي.
Mentor A: فهماك.
Learner A4: السلام عليكم.
Mentor A: ساعدينيكي.
Learner A4: حعمل خير تمام
Learner A4: مش شايفة.
Mentor A: هو في صوت.
Mentor A: طب ممكن تبعتهولي أنا أشوفها عندي إبعتلي الفايل.
Learner A4: طيب
Learner A4: أهاه
Learner A4: أبعتو لحضرتك فين معكم.
Learner A4: طيب
Learner A4: وبرضه اشتغلت على يعني عملت شوية تعديلات في اللي اختلف
Learner A4: بس هو فور يعني يعتبر كله تمام يعني كل تمام ممكن أوريك اللي هو لو حابة برضه.
Mentor A: اوكي حلو.
Learner A4: عملته.
Mentor A: لا لا حبص بس على أسامة بعد كده تمام
Mentor A: باصاب
Mentor A: معاكي سيمب لانر اللي طلع ده.
Learner A4: لا بس هو عمل وبرضه عملوا كورس مبارح الفجر من 16 ما تعملاش عن
Learner A4: بصوره تمام يعني ممكن لو خلصنا ميتينج النهارده واتفقنا على الكلام اللي جاي ممكن اخلصه وابعته لحضرتك على طول.
Mentor A: طيب عندي بس هو حلو أوي عندي بس كومنتس إن هو مش مش ريتش قوي يعني هو مش ريتش ده كده اللي انت بتقولي إيه هو ده بس إنت مثلا إنت بتقولي بيلدينغ خلي خلي ريتش أكتر خلي في سيند أكتر
Mentor A: ده كده تقريبا ده ممكن ما يعديش الدقيقة.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: ده يعني كان إيه كنت جربت كده مع نفسي بس يعني يعني لأ إحنا محتاجين حاجة ريتش يعني لو حد تفرج عليها هو أكتوالي يفهم.
Learner A4: أوكي تمام.
Mentor A: قصدي يعني ممكن تطولوا براحتكو خلوا دقيقتين ماشي براحتكم فاهمين قصدي بس.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: أكتر يعني مش حاجات كمان.
Learner A4: مشكلتي
Mentor A: حاجة تمام ثانية. وحدة هعمل حوريك.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي يعني بص مثلا لو فتحت إن هي ثاني صين على طول بيطلع اللي هو بيقولك ايت و أون ماي ماشين بات دوزن إن أوذر ماشينز.
Mentor A: اللي هو تاني سين على طول مش عايزاها تطلع كده يعني مش هو حلوة هي حلوة كريجل حاطط تقريبا 5 بلوكس كده هي دي القوس بس عايزاها تقول هي ايت ووركز أون ماي ماشين تجيب مثلا تجيب مثلا صورة حد قاعد على ماشين بتاعته مثلا.
Learner A4: على.
Mentor A: من.
Learner A4: أكتر يعني بيجوز.
Mentor A: أو.
Learner A4: بتبقى أكثر على.
Mentor A: بالضبط حد يكون ماشين بتاعه بعد كده يكون في مثلا آرو كده بيقول إن ده بيروح مثلا برودكشن أو لحد على ماشين ثانية
Mentor A: البريك تعمل علامة إكس مثلا تبقى كده.
Learner A4: أوكي أوكي ماشي فهمت.
Mentor A: مع بعض مع حتة في مثلا برضه هتلاقي السين اللي بعديه
Mentor A: بيقولك مثلا إنت عندك داوكر فايل بعد كده جنبيها بيلدينج إمرز وبعدها جنبيها مش فاكر إيه هو مش مش عايزاها كده يعني مثلا هي تقول داوكر فايل تبتدي تبقى يعني في ريتش إنفورميشن أكتر عن داوكر فايل ده بيعمل بالظبط حتى لو بطريقة سيمبل
Mentor A: بعد كده تبتدي تظهر بيلدينج إيماج يعني هي أصلا بيلدينج إيمد يعني
Mentor A: فتبتدي مثلا تقول إن هي بيلدينج تحط كارد ده وتحتيها تبتدي مثلا تحط حتى لو كلام بتبقى ديسكريبت يعني بتشرح فعلا أكسيد.
Learner A4: تمام تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: فده زين.
Learner A4: تمام ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب برضه ده برضه حتة ثانية اللي هو زي حتة هتلاقيها أول منسين بيظهر هما التلاتة بيظهروا
Mentor A: وين بتتكلم
Mentor A: لا، أنا عايزة ، لا، أنا عايزة رانية تقول مثلا داوكر فايف فيبتدي أول أول حاجة تظهر داوكر فايف تبتدي تشرح يظهر بتظهر بعد كده مثلا هو آخر ستيف اللي هو خلاص الرنينغ
Mentor A: فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: تمام ده اتوقع اللي هو الحوار ده كله في يعني لو مكتوب مضبوط.
Mentor A: ده.
Learner A4: يتظبط.
Mentor A: بالزبط مش عايزة مش عايزة سين كده يطلع فيه كل حاجة مرة وحدة
Mentor A: ده كده مش أي تاتشي خالص يعني لو حد بيتفرغ بحيث إن هو يطلعلي حاجات كتير قوي قدامي تتكلم طب لا حتة حتة خذني وحده.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Mentor A: ماشي.
Learner A4: ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: أوكي وريني بقى اللي انت عملت وريني ال يو آي أو.
Learner A4: شايفها.
Learner A4: هو ده لسا معمول فعلا.
Mentor A: أوكي نايس ذي أوز صح حلو.
Learner A4: الفم لندن صيني اللي كان المفروض احمد يعملوه بس تمام ده السكريبت اللي بيطلع.
Mentor A: لا، لحظة واحدة أبص.
Learner A4: امم.
Mentor A: ميش.
Mentor A: طيب أنزل بعديها.
Learner A4: هو ده شغال دومي داتا
Learner A4: ده خلاص يعني مصطفى حطه على جثث بعد ما قفل المحرك على طول هعمل ميرج
Learner A4: وحتسطو لو في مشاكل يعني ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي.
Learner A4: تمام دهس اللي بيطلع ده البويس بتاعه بردو موجود هنا تقريبا.
Mentor A: ال راونزر ديريكتلي صح ولا بتحطوا ولا بتعملوا تي اس عادي بحاجة على جنب وتحطوا 2 على بعض.
Learner A4: تاني معلش.
Mentor A: تستخدموا السي بي اس بتاع البرازر نفسه
Mentor A: في الجينيراشن ولا بتطلعه الوايس لوحده وبعد تحطوه على.
Learner A4: لا بنطلعه لوحده هو المفروض اللي هو بيكون موجود هنا.
Learner A4: النقص قصدي في الداتا معلش بيبقى بإسم الدب
Learner A4: كل كل مثلا يعني هو كل يوزر انتيراكسيون بيطلع كود معين
Learner A4: وعلى حسب الكود ده بيركب على.
Mentor A: أهلا بكم إمم.
Learner A4: عندنا هنا ده هو المفروض ده اللي احنا حنلاقيه هنا.
Learner A4: تقريبا بص هو بيطلع أوديوا حقيقي وكدا.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب.
Learner A4: وبعد كده هنا ده اللي هو هو بيبقى مع كل.
Mentor A: ثانية واحدة الفيديو اللي إنتو وريتهولي ده من شي.
Learner A4: ده.
Mentor A: ضد.
Learner A4: على.
Mentor A: ماشي بس الأوردر اللي فيه؟ هل هو بالطريقة دي.
Learner A4: أسامة هو اللي كان عامل الويفر أونلاين.
Mentor A: ميش.
Learner A4: تمام. وهنا كل وحدة إمتى الورد السكور الستارت إمتى.
Mentor A: يعني هو معدي معدي على كل كل ما عدا.
Learner A4: ما عدا.
Learner A4: وللأسف.
Mentor A: جوا كل السنين ولا ولا بالظبط.
Learner A4: ما هو ما هو عمر برضه كان عاملها فهي بتاخد من فوق المعمولات.
Mentor A: ماشي الحاجات اللي أنا شفتها دي دلوقتي دي طالعة من حتة اللي مطلعها عمر.
Learner A4: دي اسامة اشتغل مع نفسه وعرف اللي هي طلعها بناء على اللي احنا ماشيين بيها
Learner A4: بس هي لسا زي ما قلت لحضرتك لأن هو لحد مبارح مكانش لسه خلصان
Learner A4: فأنا لسه ما كنتش عرفتها اللي انا اعملو.
Mentor A: أنا عندي سؤال دلوقتي الأسد العمر بيجيبها ماشي
Mentor A: دي بتروح فين بقى يعني بتتحط جوا ال سيم كلاند ولا بتروح فين.
Learner A4: في.
Mentor A: قصدي مش قصدي ماشي أنت هشوفها فين بقى يعني أنا هشوفه في الفيديو هي بتطلع بقى بتتحط مثلا دي بيتحط فيلد زيادة جوه ولا إنت بتديها وهو حطها.
Learner A4: هو المفروض كل الكلام ده يعني في الخطوة اللي بعد كده إننا خلاص هنشتغل على الود
Learner A4: فكل الكلام ده المفروض هيجمع وحيزبط
Learner A4: دي في الكلام بتاعتي أو دي دي اللي انا اشتغل عليها
Learner A4: يعني مثلا كومبوزيشن والانيميشندر حياخذ بقى كل الكلام ده
Learner A4: وحيبدأ يشتغل عليه فورت إند بالكامل.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: فاهمة قصدي فكل الكلام اللي حا يتخد هنا حيتعملوا أونلاين من
Learner A4: وحيبقى شغال زي ما قلنا شغالين وضم ورموش.
Mentor A: طيب عندي سؤال برضه كمان أسامة لما خلى تشاد طلعله مثلا سيمب تينر على نفس الستروكتور وكدا وقالو بقى اكتب ليش سي ام ال صح
Mentor A: بالألميشنز والكلام ده
Mentor A: مش عارفة هو حيقدر يرد ولا إيه بس هو خد قد عشان يرنوا مرة واحدة من غير.
Learner A4: أي ما ما عرفت بس هو انا معاه ديكيمنتاشن.
Mentor A: قصدي أنت فاهم قصدي أنا دلوقتي مش عارفة إنتوا يعني أنا هبني الإشن ده جوا
Mentor A: الكود ازاي يعني هو حلو أي حاجة هنديها طلعولي بس إن إنت تبنيها.
Learner A4: فاهم قصدي حضرتك.
Mentor A: ، فأنا عايزة أعرف.
Learner A4: لا.
Mentor A: السؤال تاني دلوقتي إنت إديت ال سيمبلر
Mentor A: خد خد كم مرة تريل عشان طلعه صح؟ من غير أرز
Mentor A: أول ما قلتله يعني إنت إديت ال سيم كلاند وقلت له جنرال ماشي رحت خدت كوبي دايريكت وفتحته على الويب
Mentor A: من أول مرة طلعت زيرو آيرو ولا إطريت إن إنت تقوله بصير دي لا ارجع صلحها والكلام ده يعني عايز أعرف قد إيه.
Learner A4: تقريبا حيرد يعني.
Mentor A: إمم شكرا
Mentor A: طب هي إنت في نيو آي بس الستاد بتاعت ندى والكلام ده كله حيندي اصلا انا قلتلكو الموضوع ده.
Learner A4: ما أنا الكلام ده كله أنا حسيله انا كده كده لما أنا باجي اعمل لو جينا عملنا هنا يخش على كله ما عدا هي.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: كل الكلام ده اقول لسه موجود في المكان مثلا في شلت.
Mentor A: إن شاء أوكي طيب حاجة كمان.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: نرجع للاست ام ال.
Learner A7: هو سؤال بس هو بتاعتي لسه موجوده المفروض صح بتاعة يوسف.
Mentor A: ال
Learner A7: آخر ستب لاستيفن.
Learner A4: والرندر.
Learner A7: في أي مشاكل ولا عارفوك تمام.
Learner A4: نستخدم.
Learner A7: أوكي تمام.
Mentor A: ما إحنا قلنا لو حتتة دي نجحت يعني فيها فيها نفس فيها إيه ملامح
Mentor A: ملامح حاجة تطلع منها كويسة كلنا نشتغل فيها يعني خلاص إنها بتضم زي ما قلتلكم 4 أو 3 1.
Learner A4: إمم.
Mentor A: طيب نرجع ثاني برضه خليكم على كلهم شافوا ده إمم.
Learner A4: النادي اول مرة يشوفون.
Mentor A: افتحوا على الكوب إمم كنت أقلك إيه إنتو مش عاجباهم يعني في الأول كانت كانت بايجرا بيضة
Mentor A: ماشي وكان في علامات برنس فوق
Mentor A: ويبتدي مش عاجبني أنا حتة. البابلز الزرقا اللي في البدك والحاجات دي أنا عايزاه سبرينتس طيب
Mentor A: فدي بقى دي يعني دي مثلا ممكن تتعمل يعني تتعمل إزاي. هل هل ينفع مثلا إنتو كرييتوا مثلا باكراوند بيضة وتحطوا سبرنس لوغ ودي تبقى مثلا البيز اللي تدوه وتقولوا له إكتب على دي
Mentor A: ولا تتعملي.
Learner A4: مع لسه عشان صوت.
Mentor A: طيب شايف الباكراوند اللي ورا دي مش عجباني.
Learner A4: أنا عايزة.
Mentor A: سبرنس ستايل كان عملوا إزاي كان بيديك إنت ثابتة دايما اللي هو يديك البطالة بتطلع دي والتايتن وهكذا فاطمة
Mentor A: ثابتة في كل الفيديوس دي حاجة في الانترودي انتيراكشن دي ثابتة وبعد كده نبتدي نجيبلك سكرين بيضة
Mentor A: وفوق سبرنس لوغو ويبتدي بقى يكتب عليها كل
Mentor A: يعني عايزاه يظهر على سكرين بيضة فوق كده في علامة سبرينس فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: أم.
Mentor A: الفيديو ك ريفيرنس برضه.
Learner A4: أنا فاتحة.
Mentor A: لا.
Learner A4: الشور بتاعي.
Mentor A: مش ده مش ده.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: مش ده دا اللي طلع المرة اللي فاتت وقلتلكم مش عاجبني.
Learner A4: لا ده اللي حضرتك تقريبا.
Mentor A: أيوة أيوة لا مش ده
Mentor A: أنا أيوة
Mentor A: يمكن ده اللي حبعت إيه ماشي بس لا ده مش قصدي مش قصدي ده أنا قصدي الفيديو اللي أنا قلتهولكو عملت مش عارفة الصراحة ولا ما ينفعش
Mentor A: بس هبعتلكوا خلاص بقى إنتو كيتلا شوي.
Learner A4: اللي هو لينكد درايف.
Mentor A: أه.
Learner A4: أم أم.
Mentor A: 1 منه.
Learner A4: هو لو سمحت.
Mentor A: أوكي بالزبط ماشي بصي اللي هي الإنتراكشن دي ثابتة في كل الفيديوهات سكرينس
Mentor A: سبتة سابتة يعني لا يغير لا إرجع إرجع نتكلم فيه شوية إرجع الأول تاني فدي كدا أي حاجة ثابتة
Mentor A: اللي بتغير فيها بس
Mentor A: فكروا إن الحاجات الثابتة دي ممكن أستفيد منها. إن أنا أسيبها زي ما هي أنا جاست أغير الحاجة اللي تتغير
Mentor A: يعني لو عرفت أطلع حتى لو من غير كودينغ يعني من غير كودينغ لو إنتو جربتوا معاه ما اعرفش الحاجات
Mentor A: لو انت جرافيكس. لو تعرف تطلع مثلا تلات ثواني فيديو
Mentor A: في مثلا الشكل ده بس متشال منه فاونديشن أوف لانغيتشين
Mentor A: وات إز لانك تشيني اللي تحت بس طلعي نفس الشكل ده بالظبط مثلا
Mentor A: على كل فيديو بطلعه بس صح ولا
Learner A4: مش قصة يعني.
Mentor A: ماشي، فأنت فهمت قصدي.
Learner A4: هو الفكرة بس هو الفيديو بتاع أسامة اللي هو عمله
Learner A4: وعلشان كان يبرز فيه بس اقصى حاجة إحنا ممكن نوصلها ثواني مع السلامة ديه بالظبط معلش.
Mentor A: لا تفضلت.
Learner A4: أعتذر الله.
Mentor A: لا، لا، تمام ما فيش حاجة.
Learner A4: مع حضرتك
Learner A4: زي ما كنت بقول لحضرتك هو اللي هو عمله بس كان علشان يعني ماكسيم اللي احنا نقدر ان احنا نعملها
Learner A4: في نفس الوقت ال باكجراون مثلا هي مش عاجبة حضرتك
Learner A4: بس هو علشان زي ما قلت اللي هو فيها جرافيكس أكتر فيها ثري دي فيها.
Mentor A: لا هو اللي طلع حلو. أنا عايزة بقى نطلع من ده حاجة.
Learner A4: ما.
Mentor A: هو الحاجات دي كلها هم في الآخر يستخدموها في الشركة.
Learner A4: تمام ما فيش أي مشكلة لأ تمام يعني
Learner A4: في الفيلم الكومنت اللي حضرتك قلتيها كلها تمام مفيهاش مفيهاش حاجة.
Mentor A: أوكي فدي أول حاجة حاولوا يعني حاولوا تشوف بقى يعني مثلا الإنترب ثواني دي تطلع ازاي.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي ماشي.
Mentor A: حاجة كمان برضه يعني هو أنت مش لازم تفكر في أكثر دلوقتي أنا عرفت أطلع الأربع ثواني دي
Mentor A: حلو طلع الأستاذة طلعتها فيديو دوت إم بي فور حسميها إنتو تحت
Mentor A: دي موجودة بقى عندي خلاص دي موجودة عندي لوكل أي فيديو جينيراليت وحيستخدم دي اللي هيتغير بس.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ممكن. أطلع أطلع كنت ألريدي خلاص طلعتش تيم ال
Mentor A: تمام طلعت ال اتش ال الحلو
Mentor A: وبعدين ححوله دوت إمتي فور فأنا كده معايا 4 ثواني دوت إمتي فور ومعاي الفيديو نفسه. دوت إم بيور
Mentor A: بس عال إنتر الأربع سنوات دي أحط التايت الجديد أروح لزقهم في بعض.
Learner A4: ما ده اللي كنت افكر فيه دلوقتي.
Mentor A: بس بالزبط
Mentor A: فدي تبقي بايبلين مش لازم من الأول خالص عايزة أطلع إنتو معايا والكلام ده لا مش لازم يهمني بس إيه هو اللي يطلع
Mentor A: لكن دي حاجة ثابتة مش مش أظن كيري زي ما نقول.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: طيب فدي أول حاجة عالإنتو ماشي إيه مشي بقلبي شوي
Mentor A: ارجع ارجع معلش الفريم اللي هو اللي فيه شريطة زرقا في النص ده
Mentor A: ده نفس الحاجة برضه نفس الحاجة يعني نفس الفكرة
Mentor A: حيبقى عندك حاجة كده تطلع شريط شريط أزرق مثلا إسمها مثلا سكند فريم تحت دي سبتة عالإنتو
Mentor A: فلما تطلع يبقى عندك تلاتة كليبس عايز تلزقهم كبار.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: بسهولة جدا. هتحصل ماشي.
Mentor A: ماشي ماشي شوية كده لا عدي بقى حاول تجيب حاجة ما فيهاش حد بيتكلم ده مش السكوب بتاعنا
Mentor A: أيوا بس هدي نظر بس هي دي بقى
Mentor A: فهمت مش عايزة حاجات أنيميتد في ال باكجراوند وحاجات بتتحرك والكلام ده إحنا عايزاها حاجة كده.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: تمام يعني باكراوند بيضاء ممكن تحط ممكن وات إز لينغ تشينغ ممكن تحط ممكن تحط لوغو سبرينس
Mentor A: ويبقى دي ده الفريم. اللي أنا ببني عليه كل حاجة مثلا.
Learner A4: عامة كده كده هنا هيبقى اللوجو برينس
Learner A4: والباقي بقى أيا كان اللي إحنا فيها وأيا كان اللي إحنا فيها لوغو ثابت
Learner A4: في حاجات يعني هتبقى كده كده ممكن مثلا نثبت التوبك هنا
Learner A4: والحاجات اللي في مصر هي اللي حتتحرك يعني.
Mentor A: على وإنت بقى بتطلع إيش قال قوله مثلا الصورة
Mentor A: ده بس الفريم أنا عايز كل سين دي كل سين ينكتب على على دي يعني اكسب عليك
Mentor A: ينفع لا أنا بصراحة برضه ما عنديش نونج قوي يعني مش حريفة يعني حسن إيش.
Learner A4: تمام سهل لا سهلة.
Mentor A: بيحصل والله.
Mentor A: طيب حلو أوي ماشي تاني
Mentor A: تاني تاني افكارو هدول الأوكادو.
Learner A4: هو انا بالنسبة لي ببقى شايف يعني الحاجة كل ما كانتشكريبت
Learner A4: طيب انا ممكن العب فيها شوية بس بما ان احنا عايزين فالجراون ده بيطلع تمام يعني.
Mentor A: يعني مش مش عارف يعني بص ممكن أنت ممكن تطلع حاجة وتبعتهالي. أو واتيفر أبص بس يعني كلما لو طلعت ال إنترو دي إبعتلي الفيديو
Mentor A: ابعتلي الفيديو حتى لو فاضي يعني بص هنا مثلا بص هنا بيقولك إنت جريت
Mentor A: ودويت سيرش طول بص نطلعلك سين.
Learner A4: دي.
Mentor A: أو إنت جريت ويز مميتس طلعلك فلاش كورد يعني تدري
Mentor A: مش لازم كله يبقى كده مش لازم كل حاجة تبقى كده طبعا هتبقى صعبة يعني أصلا دي مش سهلة يعني عشان حاجة زي كده تطلع أصلا كبير جدا
Mentor A: لو قريبة منها شوية بس مش كلها مش مهتمين إننا يبقى كله بس أكيد سيرش بور أي حاجة.
Learner A4: تمام صح؟
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ده ده قلت أني كده عشان ما أكون نسيت فيديو.
Learner A4: أسمعهم لحضرتك.
Mentor A: أنا بس مش عايزاكوا تنسوا ده فنرجع نقول حاجة مش.
Learner A4: ما عايزينه بال ستايل بتاع ترين عايزين نثبت اللوغو
Learner A4: عايزين نثبت في البداية خالص وبعد كده هو التوباك بتاع النهارده
Learner A4: يبقى فيه فيجوال بسيط ال باكجراون بيضة
Learner A4: وبعد كده في شريط برده حضرتك قلت عليه هنا تمام
Learner A4: بعد كده حنمشي لحد الآخر هنا.
Mentor A: باكراوند البيضة، والبيج.
Learner A4: جراوند البيضة ممكن نبقى نحط توبك هنا الكلام يبقى بناء على ترينس كريفت
Learner A4: دا كان كومنت على اسامة عمله.
Mentor A: نفسه يكون ريتش وتشرح أكثر وزي. ما قلتلك رايح.
Learner A4: ونطول. عليك.
Mentor A: وما تطلعليش هشرح حتة معينة ما طلعش كل حاجة مرة وحدة
Mentor A: وأبتدي أتكلم يعني لا تطلع حاجة حاجة لو هي ستب مثلا فيطلع وهكذا.
Learner A4: صح.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: طيب ممكن بس طلب أخير.
Learner A4: أيوه مع حضرتك.
Mentor A: ممكن لما تقفل لما نقفل وتعمل منش.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: توريني إلا عايزة أشوف يعني عايز أشوف فاينل اشتون انا بعتهولي
Mentor A: يطلع من هو بالضبط قبل ما تعمل ميرش.
Learner A4: حاضر.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب حاجة كمان برضه هو اللي بيكتب الأتش تيم ال جوا الكود.
Learner A4: بمعنى.
Mentor A: يعني دلوقتي. أنا طلعت في نفسه
Mentor A: بطلع منه إزاي تعملين بيكتب ولا عاملين بالزبط.
Learner A4: أو لسه. ما وصلناش للحته دي يعني يعني انا بقالي اسبوعين ونصف
Learner A4: شغال مع كل أجينت عادي بس في كلام ما أعرفش. عنه أي حاجة.
Mentor A: ماشي موسم ده بيطلعلك.
Learner A4: ما أنا عامله بطريقة بس أنا مش عارف اسامة لسا هو عامله
Learner A4: الطريقة اللي عندي زي ما قلتلك هي بس في الآخر كل الكلام ده بيروح بيدخل بتاخد برامتر عادي جدا بناء على براميترز اللي عنده دي بيبعت والكرومت وبيرجعله الكود
Learner A4: بيبدأ باي بناء عليه.
Mentor A: لذا لا تشرح.
Learner A4: يعني.
Mentor A: إزاي هو اللي بيبعت لأ وريني الحاجة. أنا أول مرة أسمع عنها.
Learner A4: ماشي إحنا كنا فين مثلا ده الفايف لاين بتاعك تمام بتاعة مصطفى تمام.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: هو بتاع كل الكلام ده حلو اوي بعدم داتا بيعمل رن لل فونكشن بتاعة هي فيها كلام عبيط قوي
Learner A4: فأنا مش عارف هي بتاعت مصطفى هتبقى مش ازاي.
Mentor A: ميش.
Learner A4: تمام بعد كده داتا فيها 1 2 3 الجو باي دي وبيبدأ يعمل كيوت واللوغر كل الكلام ده بس علشان نعرف احنا ماشيين فين
Learner A4: وبعد كده بيبدأ يسلم كل الكلام ده مع بعضه ويخزنوا هناك
Learner A4: فالتربيطة. أنا ما أعرفش لسه هتبقى ماشية إزاي بالزبط فاهمة قصدي.
Mentor A: إمم أنا كان سؤالي سؤالي دلوقتي. أنا عندي سيم بلانر
Mentor A: إيه الحاجة اللي بتطلع الكود إنتو عاملين إيش إنت قلتلي بيعملها دول اللي بيعملوا.
Learner A4: ده اللي في دماغي حاليا أنا ما أعرفش الدنيا. لما انا كنت بدور وكده
Learner A4: احنا وقفنا عند آخر السيج خالص بتاعت عمر انا ولي يعني لما كنا بنتكلم معهم
Learner A4: وقفت لحد آخر السيج هنا بما إن اللي بعدها ما معادش فيها كلام.
Mentor A: ماشي خلاص إنت كده معاك هتعملي بقى.
Learner A4: بكل أبدأ أشتغل عليها في حاخد الداتا دي يعني اللي انا متوقعه والمنطقي بالنسبة لي
Learner A4: اللي أنا داتا دي من
Learner A4: وبناء عليها. هبني بس هو كده كده مع الكومنتس بتاعة النهاردة هو كده كده أنا هثبت سيمبل معين وحيبدأ يدخل عليه.
Mentor A: مش إيه بقى اللي بيكتبلك الإسم الكود ما أنا مش أنا.
Learner A4: خلينا نضيع.
Mentor A: يلا.
Learner A4: أنا برضه مش هقدر أفهم الطالب بصراحة.
Mentor A: أنا عندي أنا عندي تمام. أنا محتاجة أطلع دوت إتش إل ده في حاجات كتير قوي وبيبقى في بقى الشكل بتاع ال بيج اللي هيطلعلك
Mentor A: في الأنيميشنز سعيدة في كل حاجة وإزاي تايمز ستاند والكلام ده كله إيه بيظهر قبل إيه وهكذا.
Learner A4: هل.
Mentor A: مين بقى اللي بيفكر إن أنا مثلا السين ده أيوا أنا مثلا حظهر الأيكون دي الأول هظهر الأيكون دي الأول بيكتب ده
Mentor A: مين مين اللي بيطلع يشتري مقل.
Learner A4: هو ده المفروض هو.
Mentor A: لا، هو مش بيطلع سينكلاند بيطلع ضد في بيقولك سين ون ون ده مثلا محتاجة تكون مثلا كذا مين بقى اللي بيكتب ده حد يكتب؟ أنا سين بلان حد بيخطط لي بلان سينز كلها.
Learner A4: طيب ما هو أنا بصراحة ما اعرفش يعني أنا لحد دلوقتي ما فيهاش أي كلام من اللي حضرتك بتقوليه دلوقتي
Learner A4: فأنا بصراحة معرفش فيا ريت لو حد موجود
Learner A4: يرد او لو حضرتك معاكي تقسيم يا ريت نعرف برضه.
Mentor A: طيب هو التاس هو انتو تقريبا مش عاملين ده بقى يعني إنتو دي حتة اللي هو بس أنا أنا كنت عايزة أعرف تفكيرك انت بتقولي هبعت الداتا دي للفرونت إن
Mentor A: والفرونت إند هو اللي عمل هل في ليبرري
Mentor A: نازلة جديدة مثلا فرقتنا مش عارفة بتاخد مثلا داتا وهي جواها فيها مثلا فتكتبلك وير بيج ولا
Learner A4: هو أنا زي زي ما قلت لحضرتك هو انا لسه ما اشتغلتش بلين كامل،
Learner A4: فأنا أنا بالنسبة لي أنا طريقة تفكيري أنا
Learner A4: ببدأ الأول بخلص وبعد كده أنا شايفه أسهل حاجة ممكن تحصل في الدنيا
Learner A4: فأنا عايز بالنسبة لي بتأكد الأول متربص كله صح الأول. كل 1 بطلع الموتور منه صح الأول
Learner A4: وبعد كده حبدأ أشوف ده حيبدأ يجمع الكلام ده كله إزاي مع بعضه وأنا بحط الكلام بتاعتي
Learner A4: للي حيحصل بعد ما كلين قلت اللي أنا الأول أزبط وبعد كده لما جيت سألت بقى إزاي كل الكلام ده هيتعملوا في كلينتون قال لي كل الكلام ده حيتاخذ
Learner A4: وحيتخزن او حيتعملوا فيبدأ بقى بناء عليه يتعمله رندرنج يبقى لينك كل الكلام ده
Learner A4: ما تعمقتش في الحوار على ضمانة تعمقت في المكان ده.
Mentor A: ماشي ماشي حلو ده قصده إن أنت لو ألريدي مطلع اتش توم إل من
Mentor A: عادي تبعته للفرند إنتو بتفتحوا عالويبج بتاعة تفتحوا عليها بس مش.
Learner A4: ما اتوقع بس ممكن لأن زي ما قلت لحضرتك أنا ما عملتش ديبريتش في في الحور ده كنت مهتم أكثر بالجزئية الميكانيزم حيمشي
Learner A4: والباكند مزبوط ولا لأ.
Mentor A: طيب ماشي هي الكاسك برضه أنا الصراحة عشان ما كنتش شفت حاجة فالتسكس ممكن تلاقوها
Mentor A: فيها يعني إيه حابة كثير من من اللي فات يعني اللي كان مفروض يحصل.
Learner A1: مهندس بس أنا كان عندي سؤال
Learner A1: هو انت حضرتك عاوزانا نعمل فرونت إند ولا نعمل حاجة في الباك اند هي اللي تطلع اتش تيميل.
Mentor A: ماشي بص أنا عايزة أطلع فيديو
Mentor A: دوت ام بي فور من اتش تيميل
Mentor A: فده بيحصل إزاي. أنا قلت إن أنا بعمل أنا عندي معين بطلع ده سين بلانغ يعني سين ون ده الكلام اللي حيظهر فيه ده الفجوالز اللي حتطلع فيها يتقال فيه كذا سين تو هيظهر فيه وهكذا ملت بيل سين
Mentor A: ماشي فأنا عايزة أطلع من السين ده اللي هو ده عايزه اطلع منه دوتش تيم إل فاين
Mentor A: فده سؤالي ده كان سؤالي اللي بيطلع ده يعني اللي بيكتب اللي بيكتب أو مين اللي بيطلعه لي من
Mentor A: ده بالنسبة لي كأنها إيه يعني كلام على ورق كده كلام على ورق أنا كده قاعدة بكتب بقول ده هيطلع في كذا مين بقى أكتب حياخد الكلام
Mentor A: أيوة؟ دي نعم.
Learner A1: عند حد على ما أظن.
Mentor A: لا، هو أنا كنت كذباها ما كنتشكريبت اللي فات بس أنا كنت قلت أنا عايزة فأنتم الضو مش لازم أكتب لكم يا جماعة كل حاجة حتحصل إزاي مش لازم أكتب لكم عايزة يكتب كذا ممكن يكون في طرق ثانية غير إن إنت تخلي بالك يعني مش عارفة
Mentor A: فأنتو كان مفروض تدوروا يعني في الموضوع ده.
Learner A4: هو زي ما قلت لحضرتك والله يعني أنا لو
Learner A4: كل الناس كانت شغلها غلطان والله كنت زمانه خلصت بس
Learner A4: أنا لسا ما وصلتش للنقطة دي بس النهارده حارد على حضرتك ماشي.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب خلينا طيب نمشي بسرعة
Mentor A: ماشي عمر إنت لسه معاك الانتاع فول باي لاين
Mentor A: والكلام ده كله وال يو آي والحاجات دي كلها. وكنت بقولك إن إنت إنت إيه داخل في كل حاجة يعني أسامة برضه لو هو عشان أسامة أنا حاطله حتة ال جينيراشن.
Mentor A: لو إنت عندك فكر تاني ممكن ده يطلع منه؟ غير أنا الفكر اللي جيه في.
Learner A4: نعم.
Mentor A: اللي لم يكتبها بس زي ما قلتلكم في تخوف من الحتة دي كبير قوي. لأن هو زي ما قلتلك السؤال اللي أنا سألته في الأول لما قلت لي إن أسامة كم مرة إن هو يطلع كويس من غير قانون
Mentor A: هل من أول مرة طلع ولا مش فاهم قصدي شديد ولا.
Learner A4: فا.
Mentor A: فبس فدي أول حاجة.
Learner A4: ما شاء الله.
Mentor A: فأنت الديليفورز اللي أنا كامل وال يو آي ده مخلص ده فانت إيفرت عليك أكتر دي مع أسامة ومع نفسه
Mentor A: إنتو يعني إحنا كلنا خلاص هو ده اللى حنمشي بيه مش حغير دلوقتي مش أقدر أقول ده مش هينفع فهشوف أبروتش سام
Mentor A: إحنا كلنا ثيس.
Learner A4: تمام يا ريت بس يا ريت يا ريت الناس اللي تخلص الشغل تعمله كوش على طول علشان نلحق
Learner A4: نزبط لو في مشكلة ويحصل كل يعني كل 1 يبقى أبديتد بالكود اللي مع التاني
Learner A4: عشان ما يحصلش أي لغبطة في آخر الوقت.
Learner A1: أنا كنت أقول بس ملحوظة باش مهندسة
Learner A1: هو التاسكت بتاع الأسبوع اللي فات اصلا ما نزلتليش يعني هم كلموني الخميس اللي فات.
Mentor A: قلتلو.
Learner A1: بعتتلي بس امتى الجمعة يعتبر ما هي دي اللي انت طالباه المفروض كان مطلوب مني، فأنا عمال ابعت قلهم يا جماعة أنا أعمل بناء على إيه فأنا لسه شايف دلوقتي.
Mentor A: ما هو ثانية وحدة ثانية واحدة. ما هو إنت بقى ماشي أنا كده كده حطها نفسها هي هي في نفس أنا عاملاها.
Learner A1: أنا ما قلتش خام أصلا. أنا هعملها بناء على إيه يعني
Learner A1: مش عارف منين تايه حرفيا عمال اكلمهم وأبعتلهم يقولولي اعملها قالي عم قلها يعني.
Mentor A: طيب بص أنا دلوقتي أنا حطالك إن إنتشن تاعت البولت
Mentor A: ماشي بس ني ويل وورك
Learner A1: بالظبط.
Mentor A: كله.
Learner A1: تمام.
Mentor A: كل حاجة يعني أنا فخلاص كده تمام يا عمر.
Learner A4: أنا كمان ماشي أنا من ناحيتي كمان.
Mentor A: أحمد.
Learner A4: المفروض مع مين تاني هشتغل مع كل صح؟
Mentor A: أسامة أسامة. ميلي عشان هو اللي هيبقى ماسك حتة إزاي طلع.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي هو تبقى مين لي مع أسامة يعني حاولت تفكروا في حاجة برضه أنا برضه عايزة أفتح كلام شوية
Mentor A: إن أنا تفكيري إن أنا أخليت
Mentor A: بقى جامد كده مش لازم تستخدمه أوبني أو بي آيس لأن كدا تخلص وإنت بتطلع حاجة كبيرة، جدا فاهم قصدي هتبقى كبيرة
Mentor A: حولوا.
Learner A4: الربط.
Mentor A: يعني كنت دوروا على أوبن سورس يعني حاجة حتى لوكال آي دون كير
Mentor A: في تقريبا نماذج كويس أوي كنت بتكلم عن أحسن نموذج في الكودينغ كان قالي كوين ثري بليون.
Learner A4: ما.
Mentor A: اللي.
Mentor A: حتى لو هتنزلوله لوكال ما يهمنيش يعني المهم حتة الإم اللي بيطلع ده مش مهم كدا كدا لما ده يبقى إنت جريتيد لو هيبقى شد في الشركة
Mentor A: هم عندهم يعني فإحنا.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي أنت شوفوا لو هتنزلوا وين ده لوكال وترنوا لوكال في لاما بس مش عارفة أني أحسن في كودينغ الصراحة ما استخدمتش
Mentor A: دكتة.
Learner A4: إن.
Mentor A: خلاص شوفوا. هل لو هوغنج فيس لي ولا إنت محتاج تنزله لوكالن لوكال ينبص كاسيز، أنا تمام عادي.
Learner A4: هو أولما تقريبا محتاج فيز يعني محتاج.
Mentor A: لا، لا، آي ثينك. لا، لا، كنت منزله لوكال وتقريبا كنت شغال عليه فترة كده.
Learner A4: أنا حاولت أساسا بس هو مش حتى مش راضي يعني حاولت اشتغل بيه كذا مره
Learner A4: ما فيش ونزلت كم كان في موديل كم بس الشركة شغالة بيه او بس برضو مش مشغل.
Mentor A: طيب يعني شوف إني أحسن فدي أول بوينت إن إنت هتخلي محترم كويس تخليه يطلعلك إيه الفايل كامل
Mentor A: في حاجة تانية حاجة ثانية إن إنت.
Learner A4: ليه.
Mentor A: تعمل تعمل ماشي يعني تحط فيها مثلا البيضة وفي مثلا بليس هولدر فوق على اليمين بتاع التوبيك أو الفيديو.
Learner A4: حلو.
Mentor A: ماشي دي.
Learner A4: حضرتك.
Mentor A: دي كاسة مش هتكون كبيرة قوي يعني ممكن تبقى 60 سطر ولا وات إيفر يعني ممكن تدفعي إنت.
Learner A4: في.
Mentor A: وتخلي سين سين مثلا ياخدلك سين سين وإيه ويكتبهولك أو يحطلك جوا ده كله.
Learner A4: والله.
Mentor A: إن أنا أبعد عن إن الأرز اللي هو بيطلعهاشن آي كونتري أون إيه تطلعلي كود كامل.
Learner A4: ما هو أنا فاهم قلت لحضرتك أنا بس يعني إيه الإشكالية الوحيدة اللي عندي شغال مظبوط أسهل حاجة زي ما قلت لحضرتك.
Mentor A: ماشي.
Learner A4: ميسون.
Mentor A: أنا بس يهمني يهمني إيه مهمة عندي دلوقتي.
Learner A4: الفاينوس برودكت.
Mentor A: لا.
Learner A4: أمه.
Mentor A: حاجة مهمة عندي جدا. دي الوقت إن أنا إزايدة يطلع من البايك لاين يطلع مظبوط من غير.
Learner A4: اديني تلات ساعات بس افطر وهارد على حضرتك.
Mentor A: يبقى ريفلڤ وبيطلع من غير قرش.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: تمام طيب خلاص كده فأنت أنت مع أسامة على طول.
Mentor A: ماشي.
Learner A4: طيب.
Mentor A: مصطفى مش عارفة هو موجود هنا ولا مش موجود
Mentor A: المهم مصطفى أنا برضه يعني على فكرة مهم إن كل 1 يقرأ التانيين وبس إحنا جروبتي يعني
Mentor A: ماشي هو كان مطلوب منه إن هو يكمل ال سيمبلانر
Mentor A: كنت طالبة منه السنتين اللي فاتت اللي بيطلع ده.
Learner A4: هو تقريبا خلص الكلام ده.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي وإنه هو دي حاجة ثاني حاجة منه
Mentor A: ذي أوف ذي فاينل الفيديو يعني يعني هو حيطلع سيم بلان، ويطلع ويروح يبص عليه
Learner A4: وليتي كونترول يعني.
Mentor A: طلعلي حاجة وحشة مثلا فيجوالز محتاجة يطلع بطريقة تانية فيرجع يعدل في ال ويطلع من.
Learner A4: نموذج.
Mentor A: لا مش ماشين بلا ماشين بهيوم الرفيق.
Learner A4: نموذج فده يعتبر يعني كأنه ماشين لنا.
Mentor A: لا، أنا بقولك هو أنت هطلع لازم وهو يشوف يحكم هو إحساسه الفني يقول ده مثل ده.
Learner A4: ياخدها أكشن بعدها يعني.
Mentor A: حياخذ أكشنز بس هو هو يرجع يعدل في كومنت.
Learner A4: أيوه هو كدفاله يعني دلوقتي.
Mentor A: لا، لا مش هو اللي يأخذ أكشن. ويرجع يعدل.
Learner A4: أيوة أيوة بس.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب أوكي طيب ثالث حاجة إن هو
Mentor A: بتاعة ال سيم بلان هو برضه دي نفس الحاجة يعني كواليتي واس نوت ماشي كويس برق
Mentor A: عمر خالد إن ذي فيجوال جينيريست برضه لأن دي مرتبطة بعمر.
Learner A4: ألو.
Mentor A: على حسب ما تربطوا بيزنس إزاي هو إيه كأنكم بالضبط وتبعتوها لغروب
Mentor A: محتاجة بقى ريفيومن مين محتاجة ريفيومن هو ألريدي مصطفى و ريفيومن عمر يا جماعة بيجوزني
Mentor A: تمام لا حيرجعوا هما التنين يعدلوا في الإيه في والجينزيشن بتاعه وهكذا.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: لحد ما نوصل لحاجة إننا كلنا جنرالات بلاقي حاجة إيه حتى لو مش هندرد بيرسنت
Mentor A: أكيد مش هجرنتيني كل مرة هند بيرسنت حاجة حلوة بتطلع
Mentor A: بس يعني أكيست إيه نبقى بيرسنتاج مقبولة بلشت
Mentor A: ماشي ال ديليفيري بتاعته اللي هو سيم كلان بعد ما هو بعد ما يعدل في بتاعه هو كهيومان كيدفلتور إن هو خلاص يبقى تمام
Mentor A: ويل كواليتي مصير.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي كواليتي ده برضه يعني كواليتي هو بيرفيول اللي طالع من
Mentor A: مش بيرفيوه إيه يعني مش عايزاه برضه يرفيوه حاجات مش عايزاه يقعد يعدل هو بقى من نفسه ويرتجل والكلام. ده لا أنا عايزاه بس يرفيوه روبريك معينة تقول له مثلا شوفلي 1 2 3 دول متحققين هنا ولا لأ
Mentor A: 1 تنين تلاتة دول بقى على ال سانس بتاعه
Mentor A: اللي هو عمله من ال ال يعني مثلا أنا طلعت وطلعت وعملت ماشيين لقيت مثلا وحش جدا
Mentor A: فرجعت عدلت في إيه قلتله لأ أنا عايزة ديسكريبشن يطلع بالطريقة دي.
Learner A4: أم.
Mentor A: فعملت وعملت وشفته لقيته حلو حلو جدا في كواليتي بقى أزود دي في روج أقوله مثلا ون تشيك ديسكريبشن بتاع إنه هو يكون 1 2 3 يبقى طالع ديسكريبتش بيج
Mentor A: خلاص دي كانت.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: كان نظيف بس بدل.
Learner A4: المهم مصطفى يبقى فاهموش موجود يعني.
Mentor A: ما مش عارفة يعني إنتو لما هتدخلوا ميتين ثانية أو بكرة في ستاندرد قبلها هتدخلوا النهاردة زي ما قلتلكم مش لازم الستاند دي تلتزموا بيها بس يعني ممكن تدخل أنت وأسامة كذا عادي ابعتوا لينك على ميتينغ
Mentor A: عشان لو حد عايز جوني.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب محمد مهدي دي كانت ال
Mentor A: إنت قلت إنه هو خلصها مش محتاجين بقى نشوف هل ده بيطلع تمام ولا أهو كان ماسك.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: أنا محتاجة بقى انت لما البيبلاقي يتربص أسرع وقت ممكن
Mentor A: هو يشوف محل ده تمام يعني البويس اللي بيطلع ده
Mentor A: مضبوط تمام وكل حاجة تمام ولا لأ.
Learner A4: و وأنا بتشك وكنت شغال كمان.
Mentor A: ممكن الجنرالات. كذا مرة كده ونشوف حتة حتت الكلام. ده هل خلي بالك إنت دلوقتي مطلعه ده كنت مطلعه
Mentor A: زي ما قلت لك هو بيطلعلك كل حاجة وبعدين بيحصل إيه بيبتدي يتكلملك ده مختلف كسينكي
Mentor A: تطلع حاجة. حاجة. فالسين بيكون متقسم يكون متقسم. أكتر.
Learner A4: ما هو ريموشن اللي إحنا نشتغل بيها هي بتاخد الكلام ده
Learner A4: يعني فكره لما حضرتك قلت لو في مثلا في حاجة في الإتش تي مل بتقراها دارت.
Mentor A: أو.
Learner A4: كنت قلت كده رموشهم بتعمل الكلام ده
Learner A4: هي بتاخد الاوديو وبتضبطوا بناء على مشكلة يعني.
Mentor A: إمم.
Learner A4: وغير كدا. أنا زي ما حضرتك شايفة يعني
Learner A4: في الاول كنا شغالين كنت شغال بموك فونكشن فكنت عايزه يعني يعمل بال اي بي اي بتاع الشركة بس ال بي آي بتاع الشركة وقع فاستخدمت المين فونكشن بتاعتي
Learner A4: باوفر راوتر ولو دي تمام يعني شغال كويس.
Mentor A: ميش طيب ميش أوكي
Mentor A: طيب خلينا نروح طب ماشي خلاص يعني لو ده تمام يبقى فور ناو لو ده خلاص أنا ممكن أغير التاسك
Mentor A: ماشي بس يعني على آخر اليوم كده وهو برضه يكون حصل أو بقية الحاجات يعني تشتغلوا اليوم كله والنهارده بالليل مثلا آخر يوم 8 9 10 ولافر
Mentor A: بس معايا عشان الناس دي ممكن أغيرها ال تاسيس أوكي.
Learner A4: تمام طيب.
Mentor A: إيه ماشي إحنا كده وصلنا لأسامة ما شاء الله يعني أسامة أسامة
Mentor A: ماشي ده أنا كنت بدي افكار برضو هو نفس الحاجة
Mentor A: لو هيستخدم مثلا زي أو كذا ويقات فيلد فيها
Mentor A: كل ده عشان أحاول أقلل حتة إن ال أجينت هو اللي يكتب
Mentor A: ماشي بس زي ما قلتلك يعني ممكن نتجاهل حتة دي يعني لو اللي بيطلع ده بالظبط قدرنا نطلعه على طول من غير ما أقعد أقول ثري دي فاين تيم بلس ولازم أحكم نفسي ب 4 5 تيم بليكس
Mentor A: ولا هو سيبه هو يرتجل
Mentor A: بس حتت صغيرة. زي ما قلتلك ستاتيك تنكل كده مثلا كاملة فيها صورة باغراوند وهكذا
Mentor A: وهو بس بيفل سكشنز بس صغيرة مش كبيرة خلاص لو دا شغالة تمام خلاص
Mentor A: حتبقى أحسن أوسط تبقى اللي هو بيطلعك حاجات
Mentor A: حاجات أكتر مش مربوط بتلاتة 4 اللي هو لازم يطلع سرعة جنب وسرعة الشمال مثلا وكلام في النص أو يعمل مثلا 3 كويس بس وهكذا فاهم قصدي.
Mentor A: فده ثاني حاجة هي ثيسين وجيسن
Mentor A: ال وده أنيميشنز وده وكل حاجة جوا ده بيز على.
Learner A4: طب يعني.
Mentor A: اللحنة.
Learner A4: اللي سحر.
Mentor A: أنا كنت المرة اللي فاتت. أنا قلتلكم
Mentor A: أنا كنت ألريدي يعني خلاص إنتو إنتو نورتوا جينيراشن دي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب وكنت بقوله يعني حتة إن الحاجات دي كلها تبقى إنسايد ون فونكشن عشان إنت تبقى سهلة
Mentor A: كل ده مع بعض ماشي يا فندم الليفر بينزل أسامة بالنسبة لي إيه أنا عايزة الإشتمال فايت.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: مضبوط مضبوط هي باكجراوند البيضة والنوتس اللي أنا قلتها لكم على ده على الفيديو.
Learner A4: على.
Mentor A: أكتر ويطلعوا سينز أكثر وتطلعوا عادي وقت براحتكو بس برضه مش براحتكو قوي. آخركو 4 دقايق ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب عمر خالد برضه دي أنا محتاجة لسه أشوفها وانا مصطفى حتة ال إن هانسنت واللوك والآسف جينيريش
Mentor A: باه
Mentor A: يعني الجماعة شغلكوا ما فيش حد بيشتغل فيضان مع بعض يعني إنتو شغال مع أسامة ومثلا إيه عمر شغال مع مصطفى
Mentor A: فاهمين ما حدش حيوافق لوحده دي مهمة لازم تبقوا إيه لازم تبقوا تدخلوا ميتينغ سوا دي أهم حاجة
Mentor A: مش استندت بس والله يعني عادي إنت يا عمر مع أسامة إنتوا في حاجة إنتو محتاجين إيه تونلاين معوض عليه أو إنت عندك.
Learner A4: والله بنتكلم.
Mentor A: لوحدكوا يدخلوا 200 لوحدكوا يعني عادي.
Learner A4: أنا عارف والله.
Learner A1: هو أنا بعتت لأسامة أصلا وقلتلو ممكن أخش ميتينج معاك لأن هم طلبوا مني عشان أفهم ما ردش علي ساعتها.
Mentor A: طيب أنا حكلمك أنا هشوف فول دوكومنتيش.
Learner A1: تمام تمام.
Mentor A: يعني تيست مكتوب فول دي كومنتيشن لكل أندبوينت موجودة في الباك أند وبتكون إيه بالضبط في الليير اللي قبليها ال يو آي معمول إزاي
Mentor A: كل حاجة.
Learner A4: بس ثانية أحمد منصور لسه بعتهالك اياها لل.
Mentor A: ما زالت.
Learner A4: بطل على الشركة.
Mentor A: أنا فاتحة.
Mentor A: غير.
Learner A4: ما هو مطلوب مني؟ كلين كود بيزن ديتمنتيشن فور ووركينغ.
Mentor A: هيدي فين.
Learner A4: سرت.
Mentor A: بعتهالك الغروب يعني.
Learner A4: لا بأس.
Mentor A: طب أنا هشوفها إزاي اللي حيقعدوا.
Learner A4: هبعتلك طيب.
Mentor A: لا ممكن قصده خلينا نمشيها كده أنت قصده للكود نفسه يعني كل لاين ديسكريبشن لكل فونكشن قبليها كده قصدي
Mentor A: ده قصدي. لكن أنا قصدي هنا لحمة
Mentor A: طول دوكومنتيشن أنا عايزة فول ريدمي كبير كده ديسكريبتد لكل بروجكت.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب آخر حاجة بقى طولنا يوسف.
Learner A7: مزبوط.
Mentor A: أيوة
Mentor A: ماشي بس أنت مطلوب منك إن هي فول دوكومنتيشن بس إحنا دي الوقت يعني دي أحمد هو اللي اشتغل فيها ماشي.
Learner A7: تمام.
Mentor A: أوكي ثالث حاجة فور ذي لاستي أل ذي.
Learner A7: ما.
Mentor A: إن إنت تاخذ العشرين 1,000 بقى وتحوله لي إيه.
Learner A7: أوكي تمام.
Mentor A: مش ده وورك فلوفر حيشتغلوا برضه يو كان كود نيت مع عمر عشان هو برضه تقريبا في جنبنا
Mentor A: لو هو لو هو عنده أفكار لو عايز يقولك معينة أو أي حاجة عن الورك فلود ده يتعمل إزاي وهكذا.
Learner A7: تمام.
Learner A4: فأنا يعمل إيه بالزبط تاني اشتملت.
Mentor A: كويس.
Learner A4: طب مش دور إحنا ألريدي هاتيلي الحتة دي.
Mentor A: أنت ألريدي بتطلع دوت إمبري.
Learner A4: هو لو الفيديو طلع حيطلع بس هو ألريدي موجود يعني يعني.
Mentor A: تعملوا.
Learner A4: مش مش عارف المكان لازم اشتغل بيه بالظبط بس هو تمام يعني هي فونكشن تقريبا بيلتون في تلفون.
Mentor A: طيب أنا محتاجة أشوفها يعني أنا محتاجة أشوفها عشان زي ما قلتلك أنا شفتها كلها بتعمل فرايم يعني.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي ممكن على آخر اليوم النهارده بس اتوقع اللي هي محلولة يعني مش.
Mentor A: طيب شوفوا مع بعض شوفوا مع بعض وقلي يعني شوفوا مع بعض شوف يا يوسف معاه هل ده ألريدي بيطلع
Mentor A: من حضرتك بتتحول تمام وهكذا ولا لأ.
Learner A7: أوكي تمام.
Learner A4: ثمن.
Mentor A: عشان على بالليل كده أغير فأنت كده يوسف هو بتاع اللي هو.
Learner A4: ما.
Mentor A: خلاص بعتقد من حقكم.
Learner A7: شوف كدا.
Mentor A: حد عنده أي أسئلة.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Mentor A: ما تنساش يا عمر لما أول ما تخلص انتدريشن وريني بس اللي بيطلع دايريكت قبل أي تحسينات ولا تعديلات في النوت اللي أنا قلتها ولا الكلام ده.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Mentor A: أوكي شكرا ياسر حلو أوي كوب بالظبط.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Mentor A: النباي.
Learner A4: واخا.
Learner A1: هم سمعني.
Learner A1: هو في حاجة غريبة. حصلت مش فاهم.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A1: أصلا. أنا كنت المفروض أعمله بس هو جاني متأخر مع اسامة محدش.
Learner A4: سهلة يا عمي، انت عايز أقولك بتاعت أساسا.
Learner A1: ليه.
Learner A4: انت عملت شغل. انت عملت الشغل كله يا ابني وبوصت بتاع الجيتود صلحناه بعد كده بتاع الكريفت
Learner A4: فأنا لما نزلت اساسا بتاعك.
Learner A1: لا أنا بعثت الشغل لسارة اسمها هي سارة دي
Learner A1: قالتلي واختبرت الاند بوينز وقالتلي تمام كل شغلي تمام بس أنا مش فاهم اللي حصل برضو.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A1: أنت.
Learner A4: ميتينغ بالظبط.
Learner A1: إمم وأصلا يوم الخميس يعني هو كلمني يوم الخميس وقلت لحضرتك أنا تواصلت مع التاسكي بتاعتي ما اتبعتليش
Learner A1: فهم قال لي هتقدر تعمل الشغل وقلت له اشتغل فبعثلي قال لي هتعمل إتش تيم جينوشن تواصلت مع مهو محمد حاتم اللي كلمني لو عارفه.
Learner A1: قلتلو طب حضرتك انا حعمل ده بناء على إيه
Learner A1: أنا مش فاهم أعمل تملك من الهواء ولا أكتب إيه بالزبط ححط في داتل فيه فبعت الأث.
Learner A4: و.
Learner A1: عايز أخش معك. فما يردش علي.
Learner A4: ارجع لفرح وافهم من انها تذكر بالزبط.
Learner A1: ما هو دي أقل الأسبوع اللي فات خلاص همتيشن للمشروب.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A1: فأنا لسه فاهم إن الكود ما بيطلع
Learner A1: إلا الوقت حرفيا اللي هو المفروض اللي أنا كنت حعملو.
Learner A4: ما هي التذكرة بتاعتك راحت التذكرة دي بقت لوسام اصلا.
Learner A1: ما هو أنا أصلا قلت له أسامة قلتله أنا عايز أخش معاك ميتينغ أنا بعتله على الشركة.
Learner A1: عشان أعرف أعمل دي يعني أكتب بناء على إيه يعني هو لسا عرفان فاهم دلوقتي لما شفت ال الشير آيس كريم بتاعك.
Learner A4: تمام سهل إن شاء الله معلش بس محتاج أطلع والله عشان.
Learner A1: طب إحنا نقعد مع بعض تاني.
Learner A4: بكرة المفروض الساعة تسعه.
Learner A1: وفول.
Learner A4: أو 5 لا 5 5 بالليل 5 العصر أدرى من 15.
Learner A1: 5 النهارده.
Learner A4: بكرا.
Learner A1: خضرة.
Learner A4: ، ولو عايزة النهاردة ممكن تبعت على جروب وتشوف لو الدنيا. تمام كلنا عايز.
Learner A1: بالليل منشوفها نبدأ هو كده المشروع اللي عندك ده كامل اصلا.
Learner A4: هو لسه محتاج يتربص يعني هو المفروض لو كل 1 عمل ليزون بتاعه مظبوط يعني فخلاص
Learner A4: يعتبر خلصان يعني حعملو النهاردة وكمان ممكن ان شاء الله ان شاء الله أقل يعني نخلص النهاردة أنا أوصله.
Learner A1: قرمش.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي 1.
Learner A1: السلوك.